is it a blessing or a curse to feel
everything so deeply
it's both i think it's a blessing and a
curse
so i suppose it's it's
it the benefit it delivers is an
expanded scope of experience
and it's possible as well that
if it was done well it would be better
than anything but if it isn't done well
it's very very punishing
so i think you can make that case about
self-consciousness in people
i mean self-consciousness as a trait
loads on neuroticism
so you know and when people say i became
self-conscious
they usually mean they've become
embarrassed or anxious right and those
things do overlap to a tremendous degree
so
self-consciousness per se as an
experienced phenomenon
is associated with negative emotion
well but do you want to dispense with it
well
no because it's really informative but
you don't want to experience it
so if you're made self-conscious by one
of your inadequacies
you want to remove the inadequacy you
don't want to remove the
self-consciousness
but i mean it can get out of hand too
you know people can be so self-conscious
and so self-critical that they can't
move forward
so it can definitely be
you can have too much of you can have
too much of that that's for sure and
it's it's one of the things you do as a
behavior
therapist again a cognitive behavior
therapist is
if you have someone who's particularly
self-conscious
they'll be a litany in their head of all
of their inadequacies
and so it's like they have an inner
tormentor that just constantly
natters at them about how useless and
weak and
what inadequate they are and there's a
lot of stock arguments that repeat
and one of the things you do with
someone who is in that situation is you
have them write down
all their self-critical thoughts and you
do that
dialectically you know you help them
over many sessions
make a complete account and then you
help them develop counter arguments
not false counter arguments but you go
after it's like well is that
really true you know and here's the
here's the evidence that it's not
and so you can bolster people against
the
consequences of self-consciousness gone
amok
and that's often quite effective
why does that difficult though where
does that voice tend to come from
well it's probably um
at least in part the inevitable
consequence of being
a creature who's continually being
socially evaluated
so you you have a voice inside that's
something like
the abstracted average of everyone's
criticism of everyone and that's useful
because
it reminds you not to do things that
other people are going to
object to it it also
assuming your culture is reasonably
functional it also reminds you
not to do things that are going to be
counterproductive
and so that's one source it's like
interiorized public opinion and then
other sources are well it's also the
voice of your ideals
and that so that in that sense you might
consider it your conscience
and that can be well that's
extraordinarily useful because it points
out your shortcomings
now one of the things uh i've
analyzed this the movie pinocchio sort
of ad nauseam i would say
but but it's been very useful to me um
one of the things so that's so
remarkable about that movie is that the
voice of the conscience which is
portrayed by jiminy cricket
is symbolically associated with jesus
christ in the movie
and
but interestingly enough
there's a dialectical relationship
between
the puppet the wooden headed puppet
whose strings are being pulled
by external forces and the
conscience so despite the voice of the
conscience being symbolically associated
with christ
the conscience has something to learn
during the journey as well
and so there's like a dialogue between
the conscience and the
developing individual and the
consequence of the dialogue is the
conscience gets
more effective as the person becomes
more developed
and i think that's right because imagine
that you have the average
ideal inside you speaking to you and you
have the
the average social voice inside you
speaking to you
but it isn't really speaking to you
it isn't taking your particularities
into account
and it isn't until you engage with your
conscience
that you can craft it into something
that's actually
speaking specifically to you
and then that's that's much less
burdensome and much more effective and
so and i i think that's
reasonable because i don't think the
conscience
starts out infallible
i think we need to question our
assumptions far more than we think we
need to
around that there's so much of the
source code of what we're built upon
the stories that we were told as
children the beliefs that we've had and
built up around ourselves for a long
time
unless you actually take time away from
the urgent you never get onto the
important tasks
of thinking okay well i've held this
thing like a
like a bag like a satchel that i've
carried with me
for decades do i actually
is this serving me is there anything
even in here does this bag need to be
with me can i dispense with it
but if we're constantly and this links
back to the productivity conversation
if we're constantly chasing the urgent
forward focused
gaining and going and getting after it
we never actually
have the opportunity to sit back and
assess the foundations that everything's
built upon
if you're a building maintainer you
wouldn't build the building and then
never check on the foundations i imagine
they must have to do that fairly
regularly because that's what
the rest of the building is reliant on
to continue standing upright
there's an mba program at mcgill that's
targeted to
uh managers
not not to mba students per se
and the man who runs it
has asked his students
what they found most useful about the
program and what they found most useful
was the opportunity to get away from the
day-to-day fires of their managerial
roles
and think about the long run
the medium to long run because what
happens with most managers is they're so
busy putting out day-to-day fires that
they never
notice in what direction the entire
organization or the part their head
their heading
should be in what direction it should be
going
and we that's easy that's it's easy for
that to happen in our own lives
i mean i think that's actually why at
least part of the reason why
it's a real loss that people know so
many people no longer
attend church because you know when i
was a kid there was a lot of cynicism
and there still is about
you know one hour a week christians
they'd go to church and participate in
this
elevated ritual that was at least in
principle oriented towards a higher
mode of being and then promptly returned
to their
you know sinful work a day selves the
second they stepped out of church and
fair enough but an hour a week is a lot
more than zero
you know and you could object well most
people who were going to church weren't
engaging in this
foundational analysis it's like well
at least they were sort of doing it
and replacing that with zero doesn't
seem to be a very wise move
and so i guess that's it's sort of the
answer to your own question there too
though is you know you asked about the
utility of self-consciousness it's like
well
you can step back from your
the traps of your unthinking habits
and contemplate the whole
journey you know my colleagues and i
developed this
program online to help people do that to
write through their life
so it the past authoring program
helps people write an autobiography who
the hell am i
anyways and you think you know but you
don't
because you're complicated and then the
present authoring program helps you
identify your faults and
your virtues by your own definition
it's not imposed on you it's it's a
guided process of exploration and then
the future authoring program helps you
figure out
well if you could have what you wanted
what hypothetically what would that
actually be
and yes it's very much worth asking
yourself that question
because you're always searching for that
anyways even negatively because
your conscience will torment you for the
things you're not doing
okay while not doing in relationship to
what well in relationship to the
implicit
ideal of your conscience well what is
that and the answer is well you don't
know
and so if you're just allowing yourself
to be tortured into submission
then you're at the mercy of some ideal
that
you don't know you don't and maybe you
wouldn't want to pursue if you actually
knew
you know that's why junk carl jung said
everyone lives out a myth but virtually
no one knows which what myth they're
living and maybe it's a tragedy
maybe you don't want it to be a tragedy
and then the question what do you want
that's a really deep question you know i
mean
you that's a serious question what is it
that you should value
and people say well being happy they
don't even mean that by the way if you
decompose what people mean
when they say they want to be happy what
it turns out they actually mean is they
don't want to be miserable
they're way more concerned with avoiding
suffering than they are with
pursuing you know enthusiastic positive
emotion
so even the the statement i want to be
happy
is actually not an accurate reflection
of what it is that you want
does that not show just how little of
our own motivations we get to see
we're so good at deception that we
deceive ourselves before we deceive
anybody else
we get to see this tiny tiny little
sliver of why we are here why we do the
things we do why we think the things we
think
i saw this quote today from robert
wright that said
emotions are the executioner of our
genes
or the executor of our genes all that
they're there is to just
enact what our biological imperative
wants and then we
get to glimpse them as they run past on
the way to doing a thing
and we believe that we're somehow we're
peering into the source code of our own
mind
that's not the case well we're
definitely not transparent to ourselves
by any stretch of the imagination we
wouldn't have to spend
decades studying psychology if we were
transparent
like we're we're tremendously mysterious
to
to ourselves i'm less pessimistic about
the executors of our genes because
i i think that you know
that that pessimistic biological
determinism
kind of the pessimism sort of stems from
this
assumption adoption of the assumption
that
our genes were tooled by a blind
watchmaker and there's this
deterministic soulless process at the
base of our biological being and
i don't buy that i think it's a lot more
complicated than that so i think
even if we are tools of our biology in
some sense
the ends at which our biology are aiming
are ethical
in in an unbelievably fundamental way
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy peace
you